A dictionary is a collection
of key value pairs.
Dictionaries in Swift can be
initialized in a couple ways.
As with arrays,
you can use initializer syntax or
you can use a dictionary literal,
a list of values separated by commas.
Here between the brackets, we have the
key and value type separated by a colon,
and then a pair of parentheses
to signify the constructor.
You'll notice in the dictionary literal
the relationship between key in value is
also indicated with the colon.
And many key-value pairs
are separated by commas.
Let's see another example.
Here's my very short dictionary
of animal life spans,
which I can initialize with initializer
syntax or with a dictionary literal.
And here, you can see the type of
the lifespan value is a range of ints.
By the way, these three dots here
represent the closed range operator.
For example, this range represents
the range from 20 to 30,
including 20 and 30.
The average lifespan of a ball nosed
dolphin in the wild is 20 to 30 years.
We'll see these range operators again
when we get to flow of control.